with the looming threat of an invasion
in ukraine keeve has just signed a new
agreement with the uk and poland the
three countries will now coordinate on
cyber energy security and countering
disinformation poland's involvement is
key as nato looks to bolster its eastern
european flank in case of wider fallout
from russian aggression our europe
bureau chief crystal gamansing is in
poland tonight with more crystal
jeff poland was named in russian demands
late last year for de-escalation around
ukraine it wanted to see multinational
nato forces leaving the country but
we've actually seen the opposite happen
nato is flexing its muscle showing
russia that it will not leave member
states vulnerable
it's business as usual on the streets of
southeastern poland but everyone knows
the concerns facing neighboring ukraine
this is quite a nervous situation in
ukraine and
she definitely was not to wear like
ukrainian shoes in this fight if russian
forces roll over parts of ukraine
human impacts will be felt right across
eastern europe
mache milchanovsky a retired polish army
captain says russia is playing a long
game looking to rebuild a sphere of
influence after ukraine and the
baltic states the next will be poland
for sure the unified response of nato
and the fact that reinforcements keep
arriving in poland demonstrates the
west's willingness to push back against
the kremlin i had a lot of
experiences with the americans in iraq
as a soldier milchanovsky took part in
two overseas missions as a teacher his
analysis is informed by hard-earned
experience this is the most important if
we force him to change the strategies
to limit their ambitions
it will be the the biggest win of the
west the wild card is vladimir putin
himself what is he willing to do that is
why we are seeing nato forces being
bolstered along the eastern european
flank weapons and financial supports
being given to ukraine
and the ongoing urgent diplomatic talks
that continue
jeff crystal commencing on the ground in
poland tonight thanks crystal